wenn wir noch immer mein kollege kai
feldhaus kann jetzt haben wir gerade
gehört sie gehen davon aus dass maddie
tot ist ist es etwas die schlimmste
befürchtung sind jetzt bestätigt was
bedeutet das jetzt für diesen fall
ich weiß nicht woher diese stammen aber
wenn sich ein staatsanwalt vor die
kamera stellt und das sagt dann wird das
er mit serien wie belastbar sein
ich versuche mir die ganze zeit
vorzustellen was das für die eltern
bedeutet die ja seit jahren nach einem
abschluss suchen
und jetzt ist es möglich ist steht
möglicherweise vor dem abschluss aber
von dem schlimmstmöglichen und dann ist
es wahrscheinlich eine ist man
wahrscheinlich ihnen her gerissen
zwischen der erleichterung dass es
vorbei ist und der trauer dass das kind
nicht mehr lebt also das lassen wir die
behörden jetzt noch mal ermitteln aber
möglicherweise haben die mccanns dann
einfach tatsächlich immer mal geschafft
sind sie denn bis jetzt davon
ausgegangen dass das kind noch lebt in
allen äußerungen die sie jetzt den
letzten 13 jahren bei der presse gegeben
haben
das haben sie immer gesagt das haben sie
auch heute noch gesagt sie haben gesagt
sie gehen davon aus dass madeline lebt
bis das gegenteil bewiesen ist
ich bin kein psychologe aber ich würde
davon ausgehen dass das auch ein
großteil selbstschutz ist dass man sein
kind nicht aufgibt so lange man nicht
weiß wo es ist